How do self-awareness,
self assessment and self improvement begin and how do they continue over time?
Well,
they're all tied together and it starts with being self aware,
with being able to detach. Because if you,
if you cannot detach from yourself
then you can't see yourself.
And so people ask, well then how do you detach from yourself?
How do you learn to do that in a good drill for this is try to imagine the way
other people see you and what other people are thinking of you.
And one place where this happens,
and it definitely happened to me is when I started getting put in charge of
things, I started thinking about other people's perspectives.
What are they seeing? If you're in charge,
then what are your subordinates see you do? What are your subordinates here?
You say,
what kind of representation are they receiving?
Okay.
And if you work for someone else, it's the same questions.
What does the boss see me do? What does the boss hear me say?
What kind of representation am I making of myself?
To my boss.
Okay.
And then you start thinking about what are your friends and family think?
What do they see? What do they hear?
It's still, the question becomes how well do you represent yourself?
What shortfalls do you have?
Now when you first start looking,
it's like you're looking at an overgrown lawn.
There are some big obvious problems. So you do a broad,
just kind of general cut of the grass.
You fix some of the big easy problems that are obvious.
Once you've done that,
once you've gotten rid of some of those big obvious problems,
you notice some more detailed problems. So then you handle them.
And once you've got those handled,
you see even smaller and more detailed issues. So you start trying to fix them.
Okay?
And that's what you do with yourself.
You continually detach and then you look and then you refine and then you detach
and then you look and then you refine and then you detach and you look and then
you refine. That's what you do.
That's how you get better. And that process doesn't stop.
It can't stop because if you stop refining then,
then the weeds grow back in. The next thing you know,
you can't see yourself anymore.
Then when you can't see yourself anymore,
when you stop looking at you as yourself, then you accept,
you accept anything and that's wrong.
Don't accept the faults. Don't give yourself the benefit of the doubt.
You've got to be your own harshest critic.
Hold the line
and don't let go.